am 14 juni gingen die frauen schweizweit
auf die straße und forderten gleiche
löhne die faire aufteilung der
hausarbeit eine nationale kampagne gegen
sexistische gewandt und sie forderten
noch viel mehr keine stereotypen bilder
in der werbung solidarität mit den
frauen die in fabriken zu hungerlöhnen
arbeiten die ehe für alle gehört das
alles zu wenig muss und gibt es ihn
überhaupt den feminismus diesen fragen
gehen wir jetzt nach und zwar mit drei
philosophinnen aus drei ländern bei uns
ist ihr deborah mühlenbachs ist
wissenschaftliche assistentin am
lehrstuhl für theoretische philosophie
an der universität basel und bei uns ist
auch simone rosa müller
sie ist mitarbeiterin beim philosophie
magazin sein und streitbar
deutschlandfunk kultur in berlin und zu
gast bei uns ist auch ließ hier
sie arbeitet als freischaffender
philosophin und publizistin ging ganz
herzlich willkommen schon sind sie da ja
frau mühlebach am 14 juni war dieser
zweite große frauenstreik nun hat man ja
seit dem ersten frauenstreik einiges
erreicht gleichzeitig diskutieren ja
schon die erlanger über die anerkennung
von hausarbeit über quoten über gleiche
linie kommt der kampf für die
gleichstellung überhaupt voran
ja ich glaube ein bisschen vorankommen
mehr schon und das zeigt sich zum
beispiel auch wenn mir beim frauenstreik
bleiben daran wer sich jetzt neu anders
als 1999 noch an diesen frauenstreik
oder am termin ist ischen streichen
leben beteiligt das sind ganz viele
migrantische frauen die starke die
stimme erhoben haben und es sind ganz
viele menschen aus der lgbt community
also quere personen
kurzgefasst muss man vielleicht ganz
kurz erklären das sind also lgbt auto
steht für lesbian gay bisexual
intersection trans und eben quer
das sind eigentlich alles identitäten
oder sexuelle orientierungen die damit
benannt werden die nicht in dieses
klassische
hetero normative schema passen von es
gibt frauen und männer es gibt nichts
anderes und die stehen immer in einer
heterosexuellen beziehung zueinander
also das wäre ein fortschritt für sie
dass die bewegung sozusagen breiter
geworden ist ja weil daran zeigt sich
auch dass die themenbreite werden über
die wir jetzt öffentlich diskutieren
eben zb care arbeit ist eine ganz
wichtiges ein ganz wichtiges thema
geworden
oder eben auch anerkennung und
sichtbarkeit und von kreieren menschen
das war 1991 noch nicht so im
vordergrund und für einige geht das ja
viel zu weit und genau darüber wollen
die heute auch diskutieren was
eigentlich der kern ist zudem des
feminismus sie vor ihren haben ein buch
geschrieben geht es noch warum sie
konservative wende für frauen gefährlich
ist sie sind ja nicht der meinung dass
wir jetzt großartig voran gekommen sind
sondern sie glauben er es gibt ein
backlash ja ich denke dass nicht nur die
wahlergebnisse in ganz europa darauf
hindeuten sondern auch tatsächlich wie
sich aktuelle politische maßnahmen sei
es in österreich oder auch deutschland
äußern
also warum ich auf diese auf diese
konservativismus stadt hinweise ist dass
sie das bild von frau seien von mutter
seien ja nicht nur von
rechtskonservativen propagiert wird
sondern auch von links konservativen und
wenn man sich anschaut
inwieweit die ungleichverteilung noch
vorsicht in deutschland und österreich
auch in der schweiz natürlich aber in
einem weniger großem ausmaß
da muss man sich schon fragen wie weit
wir in richtung feminismus emanzipation
natürlich fortgeschritten sind und wenn
ich sehe dass vor allem frauen von
altersarmut betroffen sind in diesen
ländern dass vor allem frauen
alleinerzieherinnen sind dann hat sich
in diesem sektor einfach viel zu wenig
verändert haben sie vorhin gesagt
frauenbild und mutter bild was ist jetzt
genau am muttersein problem hatte ich
was ich sehr spannend finde war auch
immer einen historischen recherchen zum
buch das im deutschsprachigen raum das
betrifft deutschland österreich schweiz
dieses mutterbild ganz ganz starke züge
hat also auch von nationalsozialismus
geprägt aber auch von
theoretisch kann die pestalozzi oder
auch von aufklärern die rose wo einfach
der frau die alleinige sorge für das
kind zu kommt quasi sie trägt dazu bei
die mutter das kind für die gesellschaft
quasi zu erzielen das heißt sie ist
quasi allein verantwortlich dass aus dem
kind was wird aus dem kind ein guter
staatsbürger wird also es ist eine große
aufgabe ist also der punkt ist nicht die
mutter ist problematisch unterbinden
lässt problem aus dieser essential ist
man die frau reduziert darauf die
natürliche der funktionär auszufüllen
oder sollen in diese richtung ja frau
miller interessant ist ja es gibt gerade
jetzt am dienstag auch den club zum
thema frauenstreik da wurde munter
diskutiert und auch sehr gestritten was
eigentlich der frauen streik soll lux
den braucht oder nicht und auch was
eigentlich feminismus ist erfährt ja
erstmal auf den feminismus scheint
tatsächlich nicht zu geben genau den
feminismus team gab es tatsächlich noch
nie da war eigentlich schon immer
vielstimmig teilweise auch in sich
widersprüchlich und man kann er
vielleicht relativ schematisch zwei
hauptkonflikt achsen benennen der ein
die eine konflikt achse dreht sich um
die frage in welchem verhältnis stehen
eigentlich männer und frauen zueinander
hier gibt es den gleichheitssatz muss
der wie der name schon sagt vor allem
die gleichheit von frauen und männer
betont der sagt die bibel biologischen
unterschiede die können nicht
rechtfertigen ungleichbehandlungen vor
dem recht vor dem gesetz und vor allem
im zugang zu wichtigen ressourcen wie zb
arbeit macht und anerkennung wohingegen
der differenz feminismus eben mehr die
differenz zwischen männern und frauen
betont und teilweise auch wesen hafte
unterschiede zwischen frauen und männern
behauptet und die sich dann auch
teilweise übersetzen sollen eben in eine
ungleichbehandlung von frauen und
männern in der gesellschaft dass es zum
beispiel wichtig wenn es um mutterschutz
gibt gleichheits und referenz für
mindestens die widersprechen sich auch
nicht nur sondern die ergänzen sich
manchmal auch ganz gut aber die können
sich natürlich auch in den haaren liegen
eben wenn es zum beispiel um so
behauptungen geht wie frauen sind
automatische näher an den kindern näher
der natur und die andere große konflikt
achse die man auch zeigen kann ist wie
konflikt achse zwischen einem busen
feminismus und einem arbeiterinnen
feminismus da geht es um die frage ja
wofür kämpfen wir dann eigentlich was
heißt denn eigentlich gleichberechtigung
geht es daher um formale rechte um
teilhabe an macht um
leistungsgerechtigkeit wie der schwarze
feminismus schon immer der bürgerliche
dem zögerlichen feminismus schon immer
will
oder geht es um noch mehr geht es auch
um soziale freiheiten zum beispiel um
eine anders verteilungen eine
umverteilung von arbeit oder auch eine
bessere entlohnung von arbeit wie der
arbeiterinnen feminismus schon immer für
sich beansprucht und die beide dinge
waren die heute sprechen also sowohl
über die kategorie geschlecht eben wie
sehr ist es eigentlich wichtig dass
frauen anders sind wie männer oder eben
gerade nicht wichtig nicht richtig zum
beispiel für die zu sprechen von rechten
und das andere ist diese frage der
arbeit und wie wir die arbeitswelt
gestalten sie haben wohin genickt
familie bach ja also ich gerade bei
diesen gegensatz zwischen eben eher zum
bürgerlichen und sogar arbeiterinnen
feminismus wie sie es genannt haben
machte schon so eine ziemliche
unterschied auf darin wofür man
eigentlich kämpfen will
und wir haben ja grosse diskussionen um
die lohnungleichheit und während der
liberale bürgerliche feministinnen sich
oft auf diesen unerklärlichen
lohnunterschied konzentrieren der eben
nicht auf ausbildungs unterschied
zwischen männer und frauen oder
qualifikationsniveaus und so weiter
zurückzuführen ist weil halt so ein
feminismus wenn auch nicht weiter in
ihrem buch 999 ein manifest gerade neu
erschienen wo sie ja dafür plädiert dass
wir eigentlich eine
kapitalismuskritische haltung haben
müssen wenn wir richtig geschlechter
ungerechtigkeit aufheben wollen
und das gerade in bezug auf die schweiz
finde ich sehr eindrücklich geschildert
von der schweiz ökonomin mascha madörin
die noch nicht aufgezeigt hat dass in
der schweiz wenn wir uns überlegen was
ist eigentlich arbeit und wir arbeit als
etwas verstehen dass wir brauchen um
unsere gesellschaft gut organisieren zu
können dann zeigt sich dass frauen und
männer eigentlich stunden mäßig genau
gleich viel arbeiten denn zur arbeit
damit die gesellschaft funktioniert
gehört auch keine arbeit es gehört auch
hausarbeit und so weiter also care
arbeit die betreuungsarbeit masche von
kindern aber vielleicht auch von älteren
menschen vom kranken menschen als
ressource angelegenheiten essen kochen
einkaufen putzen kinder erziehen kranke
pflegen all das gehört sozusagen in den
gegner der arbeit unseres madörin da im
zeigt ist das obwohl frauen und männer
gleich viel arbeiten der lohnunterschied
zwischen frauen und männer als frauen in
der schweiz 110 milliarden franken
weniger verdienen wenn man alle arbeit
anschaut die hier berichtet wird und das
ist weil frauen hat unglaubliche mengen
von gratis arbeit leisten also der punkt
ist so ein bisschen derjenige dass man
sagt man spricht sehr oft über diese
sogenannten gender pay gap und klein
damit wirklich für dieselbe arbeit für
die gleiche einstellung unterschiedliche
löhne das gibt es darüber hinaus und das
ist die andere forderungen mascha
madörin zum beispiel wird darauf
hingewiesen wie viel arbeit sozusagen
umsonst geleistet wird die niemand
entlohnt das ist ja eine zentrale
forderung geben jetzt auf kommt auch in
diesem in dieser diskussion darüber
wofür haben die frauen jetzt einen nicht
gestreikt ist aber extrem umstritten ist
das jetzt wirklich ein anliegen des
feminismus ein großes problem sehe ich
und findet das haben sie ja schon schön
angesprochen ja also die frage für mich
er dann noch weiterführende können wir
uns auch diese geschlechtergerechtigkeit
leisten
und vielleicht noch davor wollen wir sie
uns tatsächlich leisten denn das hätte
wirklich einschnitte zur folge
es kommt aber noch etwas den
konservativen entgegen nehme ich das
neoliberale system ja auch darauf setzt
diese frau ist kostenloser ressource zu
haben ja also diese vorstellung der mann
jetzt dannheim jahr von dieser rauen
raubtier kapitalistischen welt und
daheim ist an dieser heile welt idylle
wo dann die frau vielleicht kocht und
auf das kind schaut das ist alles gut
und schön aber hat natürlich
konsequenzen punkt einzig und die
abhängigkeit von frauen und natürlich
also und ein schlechterer bezahlung und
wir haben natürlich auch dieses dieses
verhältnis zwischen mann und frau
das natürlich niemals auf augenhöhe
stattfinden kann
solange ich als frau auch angewiesen bin
finanziell wirtschaftlich auf meinen
partner und auch im alter darauf
angewiesen bin können wir nicht von
freien emanzipatorischen
geschlechterverhältnisse reden
also ich finde da wären mit diesem
gender pay gap ganz ganz viele fragen
angesprochen aber vielleicht auch nicht
so kommuniziert dass er so im alltag
extremismus ankommt also auch bei frauen
in prekären berufen ja die fühlen sich
nicht angesprochen oder frauen die es
geschafft haben
ich glaube es geht es gerade eine runde
zu schnell oder wir sind jetzt sozusagen
von von der frage der der der kurzen der
gerechtigkeit bei den löhnen also dass
des gleichen lohns sind wir bei der
radikalen kapitalismuskritik von ramzi
fraser gelandet das machen wir noch ein
zwischenschritt
es gibt ja diese neben sogenannten
liberalen feminismus sie haben ihnen
auch den bürgerlichen feminismus genannt
ich glaube es steht niemand vielleicht
so sehr für diesen feminismus wie sheryl
sandberg die ehemalige ceo von facebook
die ein buch geschrieben hat mit dem
titel lenin und das ist zugleich
programm nämlich die idee die frau die
muss sich eben auch mit anstrengen es
geht darum dass die frauen sich jetzt
mal hinstellen und zugang zum kader
zugang zur teppiche tasche zur chefetage
selber verlangen
ja also das spricht ist natürlich einen
wichtigen punkt an nämlich dass wir
wirklich immer noch ein problem haben in
der unterschiedlichen selbsteinschätzung
und selbst wertschätzung von frauen und
männern also frauen sind eben in ihrer
selbst wertschätzung oft sehr viel
zurückhaltender sagen wir mal als männer
was ganz viel mit stereotypen
zuschreibungen von geschlechter bildern
von geschlechterrollen zu tun hat und
darauf werden wir bestimmt nachher auch
noch zu sprechen kommen warum das
eigentlich immer noch so ist und warum
diese bilder die wir im kopf haben von
was ist eigentlich typisch weibliches
typisches männliche verhalten nach wie
vor so eine wichtige und bedeutsame
rolle in der strukturierung von
gesellschaft haben was man aber sender
und wir kommen ja gerade jetzt für eine
diskussion rund um ein wenig
feministisch einen bürgerlichen
feminismus im kontrast zu einem
vielleicht eher
sozialistisch geprägten oder arbeiterin
feminismus was man diesen läden in
feminismus eben ankreiden kann ist dass
er die sozioökonomischen voraussetzungen
von zugang zu zum beispiel chefetagen zu
wenig in den blick nimmt also dass er
eben sich nicht klar macht dass es nicht
nur darum geht dass männer und frauen
die gleichen löhne bekommen sondern dass
jede frau sich mit ihrem lohn natürlich
auch ein gutes leben leisten können muss
also ein leben das eben nicht nur die
grundbedürfnisse sichert sondern ein
leben das auch ein leben in gleiche
achtung innerhalb der gesellschaft
garantiert und damit verbunden sind eben
auch notwendig den zugang zu bildung zu
kultur und zu gesundheit und dass das
ist hat sozusagen diese art von den
feminismus nicht auf der pfanne wenn er
sich sozusagen immer nur an die
chefetagen und andy glasdeckel richtet
also dass man könnte ja umgekehrt sagen
das ist feminismus für die 99 was tracer
wie lisa sozialistische feminismus und
was sie macht des feminismus für ein
prozent wäre das so ein bisschen sehr
zugespitzt gesagt genau vertreibt diese
art von den feminismus natürlich nur die
interessen einer kleinen relativ
navigierten gruppe von frauen wohingegen
sich diese art von fraser sozialismus
feminismus eben natürlich wirklich an
die breite masse aber irgendwie ist das
doch auch schläger so macht man habe ich
den eindruck jetzt haben wir den frauen
oder was heißt hier wir es wurde uns
frauen lange gesagt jetzt strengt euch
mal an ladies jetzt geht man auf die
hinterbeine verlangt gleiche löhne geht
die chefetagen erhebt eure stimme
strengt euch an machten studienabschluss
haben wir das gemacht und jetzt heißt es
plötzlich moment mal das ist hier nur so
für die 1 prozent nach oben
jetzt kümmert euch irgendwie um die 99
prozent die gar keinen zugang haben also
noch einmal was ist denn jetzt der kern
des feminismus und müssen wir jetzt alle
plötzlich für arbeiterinnen rechte
kämpfen von migrantinnen also dass das
hinterlistige finde ich jetzt auch an an
dem buch liening ist ja auch diese
illusion windows nicht schaffst dann
liegt an
hier ist ja auch dieses kapitalistische
dogma also du musst das irgendwie
schaffen streng dich an und wir sehen
das ja auch an der konservativen politik
auch den ministerinnen die wir jetzt
haben die dann auch ganz öffentlich auch
im frauenministerium getönt haben ja
also wir müssen uns mehr anstrengen
frauen müssen einfach mehr tun sie sind
auf jeden fall auf dem gleichen level
wie männer
aber ich sehe dass das das große problem
ist das natürlich all die eben aus
diesen privilegierten backgrounds kommen
wie kann ich also jetzt mit dem
feminismus nicht nur eine randgruppe
ansprechen sondern alle
das haben wir längst verlernt deshalb
wäre ja auch jetzt meine meine mein mann
meine vision dass der feminismus ja
tatsächlich sich in richtung
emanzipation einer richtigen
emanzipatorischen vision
weiterentwickeln muss denn ansonsten
wären wir immer diesen vorwürfen
ausgeliefertsein punkt ein sie vertreten
nur frauenanliegen dann stellt sich die
frage was seine frau ja und was sind
dann spezielle frauenanliegen und dann
werden wir immer in dieser differenz
sein wir müssen uns rechtfertigen warum
frauen mehr oder weniger verdienen
sollen das frauen tun können und was sie
nicht tun können
also was mir fehlt an dem feminismus
heute vielleicht oder was ich mir
wünschen würde tatsächlich den blick ein
bisschen zu einer emanzipatorischen
mission zur eröffnung ist auch die die
fräser versucht also tatsächlich die
mehrheit der frauen zu erreichen und
nicht die privilegierten die eben schon
knapp vor dem durchbruch sind und
vielleicht versonnen decke stehen die
mehrheit der frauen ist eben nicht bei
der ge seinen decke die kämpft mit
alltagsproblemen und alltags
diskriminierung und daran anschließend
und auf ihre frage zurückkommen sollen
wir denn jetzt alle vier arbeiterinnen
was auch immer arbeiterinnen sand sein
sollen sprechen das kann wer kann ich
und das ist auch gar nicht die idee
glaube ich glaube die idee wäre er
frauen und nicht cis männer das heißt
nicht männer die schon bei geburt als
männer
so bezeichnet wurden alle die leute ins
boot zu holen und ihre unterschiede und
aber auch ihre gemeinsamkeiten irgendwie
festzustellen also dass wir miteinander
ins gespräch kommen und ich werde
nie für eine gruppe von schwarzen frauen
in der schweiz reden können weil ich als
weiße frauen einfach nicht in der lage
dazu bin zu verstehen was denn
eigentlich ein schwarzer feminismus in
der schweiz ganz genau
für bedürfnisse hat also ich kann zu
hören ich kann ich kann im dialog treten
aber es geht nicht darum dass ich für
schwarze frauen für migrantische frauen
und vertrauens menschen rede
aber zugleich ist eines der kernanliegen
des frauen streiks gewesen zu sagen wir
kämpfen auch für die arbeiterinnen
fabriken weltweit die zu holen arbeiten
ja aber dass das heißt nicht zwingend
dass man die jury sprecher und und ihrem
bedarf ist ganz klar also dass
aufmerksam und von sich also ich glaube
nicht dass wir da sehr weit auseinander
sind ich würde es nur glaube ich ein
bisschen anders sehen also die
solidarisierung ist das eine
solidarisierung heiß glaube ich unter
anderem auch dass man sehr wohl auch im
namen anderer spricht und sich für
andere stark macht sowie weiße frauen
sich natürlich auch für die rechte von
schwarzen männern stark machen können
oder heterosexuelle menschen für die
rechte und die gleichberechtigung von
homosexuellen ich glaube dass es auch
sehr wichtig dass das passiert das heißt
aber natürlich nicht dass man für sich
beansprucht die position frau weg nehmen
zu können
also natürlich müssen wir weiter zu
hören und in unterschiedliche stimmen zu
wort kommen zu lassen um überhaupt zu
verstehen ja was sind denn die
spezifischen problemstellungen die
person aufgrund ihrer komplexen
identitäten teilweisen wir sind ja nicht
nur frauen sondern wir sind eben auch
eher religiös oder nicht religiös wir
haben einen ethnischen hintergrund wir
haben vielleicht integrations
hintergrund und so weiter
diese komplexen identitäten führen ja zu
ganz unterschiedlichen sozialen
positionen die ganz unterschiedliche
soziale herausforderungen auch
bewältigen können müssen häufig nur ganz
kurz weil ich glaube wirklich wir
sollten diese diese idee dass feminismus
irgendwas zu tun hat mit anti
kapitalismus
ja noch besser verstehen sie ja sie
haben sie ja was ist denn genau der
zusammenhang kann man das so einfach
sagen der der zusammenhang zwischen
feminismus und kapitalismus oder eben
antikapitalistisch antikapitalisten weil
das ja jetzt so aufkommt dass er das ist
eine farce und feminismus gibt der ganz
stark antikapitalistisch ist also nancy
fraser gehört dazu aber das ist ja eine
forderung die jetzt immer wieder auch im
raum steht habt ja wahrscheinlich zu tun
mit der frage was bewerten die ihr
überhaupt wie in der gesellschaft
stichwort entlohnung der hausarbeit
genau also man kann glaube ich
es gibt teile des feminismus das ist
auch nicht ganz neu sondern es gibt zum
beispiel schon seit den siebzigern eine
kampagne für die die sich einsatz für
die bezahlung von lona von
haushaltsarbeiten eine wichtige person
ist da zum beispiel auch sehr viele die
diese kampagne ins leben gerufen hat
oder vertritt und dass die die
perspektive ist erst einmal die zusagen
an dieser zweiteilung der gesellschaft
in unbezahlte mehrarbeit auf der einen
seite und lohnarbeit auf der anderen
seite an dieser schieflage müssen wir
etwas ändern entweder indem wir es
hinkriegen unbezahlte mehrarbeit
tatsächlich gleichmäßig und gerecht auf
die unterschiedlichen geschlechter zu
verteilen so dass auch männer ihren
verzehr sozusagen da übernehmen oder
aber das sind unterschiedliche
forderungen es gibt auch leute die eben
für eine bezahlung dieser form von
arbeit sich einsetzen das könnte sondern
zum beispiel sich ausdrücken in einem
grundeinkommen und wofür sind sie ich
glaube ehrlich ich bin ein bisschen
skeptisch dieser grundeinkommens idee
gegenüber weil ich glaube dass damit die
gefahr einhergeht dass es ein sehr gut
bezahlten lohn arbeitsbereich gibt und
einen schlecht bezahlten care
arbeitsbereich und die damit auch die
alte gefahr einhergeht das große gruppen
der gesellschaft abgedrängt werden in
diesen schlecht bezahlten care bereich
also ich glaube nicht dass es unbedingt
so emanzipatorische kräfte entwickeln
muss dieses modell
ich glaube aber ehrlich gesagt dass die
andere das während ein zweiter vorschlag
dass
eine andere art von organisationen
dieser care arbeit tatsächlich
vielversprechend sein könnte und da
lohnt sich eben unter anderem auch der
blick in den globalen süden zu
insbesondere indigenen gruppen und
frauen die noch ganz andere ideen haben
von kollektiven wirtschaften von
kollektiven arbeiten von solidarischen
eigentumsformen auch die auch ganz
unterschiedliche ideen andere ideen
haben im umgang mit so großen geteilten
ressourcen wie wasser und und wissen und
ich glaube da hin da wird sozusagen ein
recht spannender wind werden ja ich bin
da etwas skeptisch zum einen also diese
illusion ja wird natürlich können wir
von anderen lernen
ich bin immer so genau dazu zu bringen
dass dieses ideal ja also dieses
familien ideal auch die frau arbeitet zu
hause und übernimmt die meiste arbeit
das ist ein sehr junges modell also vor
100 150 jahren erfunden gestärkt durch
sämtliche ideologien durch konservative
player die kirche und religion
aber früher war es tatsächlich auch
nicht leicht bei dass frauen daheim
geblieben sind gerade für die unteren
schichten was vollkommen klar dass
frauen mitarbeiten und kinder von einer
großfamilie erzogen wären also dieses
ideal also mit mir kämen war sie zurück
zudem wo wir schon einmal waren
interessanter finde ich da viel mehr
ganz allgemein zu hinterfragen warum
männer sich nicht vielmehr auch für
arbeit interessieren
zum einen ja hat natürlich mit der
bezahlung zu tun es gibt aber auch sehr
viele männer die sehr gerne bei den
kindern bleiben würden
die sich sehr stark in die erziehung
einbringen und ja und das bekanntlich
auch ein bisschen an an der aufspaltung
von feminismus und wer traf daran
teilhaben ohne diese männer wird es
nicht gehen also wenn ich mir überlege
die fortschritte die wir haben ja auch
sei es überhaupt vorschläge wie
am väterkarenz papamonat was auch immer
das sind natürlich kritisch zu
beurteilen aber die wären quasi ohne den
einsatz und dieses bewusstsein dieser
männer gar nicht möglich und denkbar
gewesen
also für mich ist interessanter
zuschauen wie haben sich berufe die
einst in männlicher hand waren das waren
erziehungsberufe früher in weibliche
verwandelt was hat das für folgen
schlechtere bezahlung aber es gibt
männer die daran interessiert also nie
bekomme ich die wieder hinein bezahlung
ist eine sache
das andere ist aber auch die
wertschätzung der verkennung ja und auch
männer während diskriminiert also wenn
wenn nicht die kleinen
kindergartenpädagogik anschauen
also männer die dort arbeiten wollen die
sich da einbringen wollen
sie stehen unter generalverdacht also
diese diskriminierung gibt es nicht nur
auf der einen seite dass frauen
diskriminiert werden sondern tatsächlich
auch männer und ich glaube gesagt da
diesen gedanken reinzubringen wirklich
diesen emanzipations gedanken rauf zu
holen und zu sagen
am ende wäre ja eigentlich beides
möglich wäre so für mich ein ziel frau
miller hat er ja vorhin diese
zweiteilung ausgemacht ende der arbeit
fair aufteilen oder care arbeit oder
überhaupt freiwillige arbeit entlohnen
sie sind ja selber auch sehr
aktivistisch tätig sie arbeiten unter
anderem immer wieder bei der autonomen
schule sind da sehr engagiert für die
rechte von abgewiesenen asylsuchenden um
sie will ich sie richtig verstanden habe
sagen schon eigentlich müssen wir
darüber nachdenken ob diese ganze arbeit
nicht auch bezahlt werden müsste oder
zumindest aufgewertet es ist halt sehr
zweischneidig weil einerseits bin ich
natürlich der ansicht dass leute wie ich
und ganz viele andere die bei der
autonomen schule in zürich arbeiten wir
eine arbeit übernehmen die eigentlich
die stadt zürich oder der kanton und
fleiß gott erstarrt übernehmen sollte
nämlich unter anderem deutschkurse für
leute die frisch in die schweiz gekommen
sind aber auch abgewiesene asylsuchende
weil ganz viele können nicht zurück auch
wenn sie einen negativen asylentscheid
bekommen und da übernehmen wir eine
arbeit die ich finde sollte eigentlich
jemand anderes übernehmen aber es ist
natürlich auch so dass das projekt ein
eremit katholische
das ziel verfolgt nämlich es ist ein es
erfolgt ein ideal von bildung bei dem
wir alle gegenseitig voneinander lernen
und das nicht einfach so ist dass ich
dort hingehe und irgendwelchen leuten
deutsch beibringen sondern so wie die
schule organisiert ist funktionieren wir
gar nicht erst so dass es irgendwie
staatlich übernommen werden könnte
das hat ja insofern zu tun mit dem
feminismus wiederum dass wir die welt
nur verändern können zu mehr gleichheit
hin zu mehr gleichberechtigung in wenn
wir beginnen solche arbeit zu anerkennen
und wir könnten sie zu fragen was hat
sich die autonome schule zu tun mit
gleichstellung und frei meniskus und
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe
jetzt ihnen darum auch zu sagen das ist
auch wie care arbeit ganz viel arbeit
die sehr sehr viele menschen freiwillig
tun oft eben frauen tun
und die bleibt immer irgendwie umgesehen
ja es gibt geht eigentlich in eine
ähnliche richtung wie der arbeit ist
einfach an wissen
eine andere form von care und da frage
ich mich schon ob so ideen wie ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen nicht
auch sinnvoll wären weil das was sie
angesprochen haben die gefahr dass dann
gewisse leute abgedrängt werden in diese
eben hat schlechter bezahlten er aber
das passiert ja jetzt schon also und ich
glaube wenn wir es schaffen würden unser
verständnis dessen was arbeit eigentlich
ist ein bisschen loszulösen von von der
vorstellung die wir jetzt haben nämlich
ganz bestimmte berufe sind lohnarbeit
und der rest ist keine arbeit
ich glaube dass das wäre befreiend für
ganz viele menschen gleichzeitig geht es
natürlich jetzt mit blick also weil das
ist der zweite teil der schieflage denen
wir jetzt noch nur am rande gestreift
haben
es gibt ja der arbeit die durchaus
professionalisiert wurde und teil des
arbeitsmarktes ist also der gesamte
pflegesektor erziehungs sektor auch
reinigungs sektor und auch da beobachten
wir ja eben das da maßgeblich frauen
arbeiten und eben zu sehr
sehr schlechten löhnen und eine der
großen feministischen anliegen ist es
natürlich diese art von typisch
weibliche arbeit aufzuwerten auch
monetär und das würde eben ein bisschen
im widerspruch stehen
zu solchen grundeinkommens ideen weil
das kann man natürlich mit blick auf die
krebs grundeinkommen nicht machen also
man kann ich jedes jahr sozusagen das
grundeinkommen irgendwie um wirklich
wichtige beträge nach oben korrigieren
gleichzeitig wenn ich jetzt denke in den
projekten bei denen ich arbeite treffe
ich auch oft frauen über 50 über 60 oft
mit migrationshintergrund auch für die
wie ein grundeinkommen ein
bedingungsloses grundeinkommen eine
chance sich aus der abhängigkeit von
ihren männern zu befreien
also die sind tatsächlich nur in
unbezahlte arbeit tätig gewesen ihr
leben lang haben oft eine schlechte
ausbildung oder kaum eine gute
ausbildung genossen und für die wird es
tatsächlich ein befreiungsschlag
also wenn wir wirklich davon ausgehen
dass jetzt frauenemanzipation auch
heißen würde
finanzielle unabhängigkeit dann glaube
ich tatsächlich dass ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen gerade in diesen
verhärteten schichten ja so einfach die
frau weiß wenn sie ein mann verlässt
kann sie nicht alleine überlegen das
geld reicht einfach nicht sie hat keinen
ausreichenden zions anspruch oder so
dann glaube ich dass das in diesem
bereich wirklich an zu denken wäre wie
viel das da an geschlechterverhältnissen
auch positiv verändern könnte ich würde
gern mal noch einen schritt weiter gehen
und noch tiefer bohren auch bezüglich
des zweiten anliegens des denn sie
hatten am anfang so schön aufgezeigt das
ist einerseits nun diese fragen der
ökonomie geht der arbeit aber anders als
auch um diese frage der weibliche körper
differenz versus gleichheit und in
diesem zusammenhang kann man ja einfach
auch mal festhalten dass doch
interessant ist es jetzt fragen wieder
auf sprechen die eigentlich vor 70
jahren schon simon depot war
und ja auch nicht als erste beschäftigt
haben es ist 70 jahre her dass dieses
buch von der von simon depot war das
andere geschlecht erschienen ist
worum ging es genau in diesem buch
respektive oder ich kann vielleicht so
sagen es gibt diese eine these die immer
alle kennen nämlich m tief man kommt
nicht als frau zur welt man wird ist
so werden wir zu frauen wie kommen noch
in gas frauen zu welt großes schwand
worden
interessant finde ich ein buch oder das
was sie für mich so wie soll ich sagen
so aktuell auch macht und deshalb die
dierig sich auch gerne es dass sie schon
große betonung auch darauf legt dass
tatsächlich die ungleichbehandlung von
frauen dann bedingt wenn sie auch mutter
wird also dass die gebärfähigkeit der
frau scheinbar unter anführungszeichen
dazu beiträgt sie in einem unterdrückten
verhältnis zu belassen oder sie
zumindest zu diskriminieren auf eine
ganz spezielle art und weise und ich
finde dass dieses eine thema tatsächlich
noch immer brandaktuell ist bloß die
zweite these natürlich dass diese
ökonomische ungleichbehandlung auch
folgen trägt also auch ihr hinweis
darauf dass frauen unbedingt
wirtschaftlich unabhängig sein müssten
dass es sich wirklich überlegen sollten
ob das sich auf mutterschaft einlassen
ich glaube an ein zitat ist auch das
mutterschaf tatsächlich in unserer
gesellschaft sklaverei bedeutet auch in
wien
ob ich jetzt zustimme oder nicht dass
ich mal offen mal in einem gewissen
sinne stehen mir hierzu sind alle ich
habe kinder ich fühle mich nicht was
kraft würden sie jetzt alle sagen jaja
frau gleich sie argumentieren aus der
privilegierten situation der weißen gut
gebildeten frau also nein also ich hab
auch ich hab auch ich habe auch ein kind
also ich nicht kenne mutterschaft auch
von dieser von dieser lage nein ich bin
nicht sang sklaverei aber tatsächlich
denke ich dass ich ich partner auch mit
dem thema der ungleichbehandlung durch
mutterschaft auch mit arbeit die danach
vor ort tatsächlich noch mal anders
gelesen habe
also dass die die these von von der
zurückstellung von biologischen
unterschieden sind jetzt nicht so
wesentlich oder sind gemacht also ich
glaube es gibt tatsächlich einen
schlagenden punkt im leben von frauen
das ist tatsächlich diese diese
biologische ausgesetzt da geht es gar
nicht darum ob ich aktuell kinder
bekommen kann sondern tatsächlich was
bedeutet es menstruation zu haben
also ich denke da auch an an eine starke
kritikerin von butler die barbara duden
die sagt oder die drei jahre nach der
schrift von butler gemeint hat dass ihr
die materialität da nicht nicht vorkommt
also die man eingestellt genau dass das
was sie einfach kennen der situation ist
unter diskriminierten situation der
normale menschen mit frauenkörper
ausgesetzt sind ja das finde ich es
schlag haben wir simon tobor auf dem
tisch wir haben frau butler ist judith
butler das unbehagen der geschlechter
auf dem tisch und wir haben barbara
duden auf dem tisch informeller sie kann
bestimmt aufräumen oder einfach mal kurz
die sachen kontext realisieren worum
worum geht es denn genau was hat judith
butler nachher korrigierbar simon aboud
also ich glaube wir waren ja gerade bei
der idee dass man eben nicht als frau
zur welt kommt sondern zu frau gemacht
wird und das was bei boa schon angelegt
ist und ich würde eher sagen butler hat
das dann einfach noch mal vertieft und
noch mal ein bisschen in andere
richtungen gedacht ist die idee dass
eben auch unsere bezugnahme auf das
biologische geschlecht und damit auch
zum beispiel die möglichkeit des mutter
science des gebets und so weiter immer
schon durchdrungen ist und imprägniert
ist von sozialen ideen davon was es
eigentlich heißt eine frau zu sein oder
ein mann zu sein und ich werde sagen
auch ein mann zu sein
ja oder männer sind auch kommen auch
nicht aus männer zur welt wie ihr
genommen
natürlich werden männer und auch zu
männern gemacht dass werden zum beispiel
damit an also das fängt ganz drastisch
gesprochen ehrlich gesagt damit an dass
zb intersexuelle babys in deutschland
nach wie vor direkt nach der geburt
meistens operativ angeglichen werden
aber das beginnt natürlich es geht dann
weiter mit einfach eine rosen und einer
blauen erziehung wenn man es nutzen ein
bisschen plakativ sagt damit zum
beispiel dass man mädchenkleider anzieht
und sagt sie sind sehr schön aus und
jungs aus lacht wenn sie auch gleich
zehn anzug anziehen wollen oder dass man
wenn ein mädchen im baum hoch klettert
vielleicht dazu verleitet ist zu sagen
oh gott hat musste so hoch klettern tu
dir nicht weh und einem junge vielleicht
eher er schneller sagt 'mensch kannst du
toll klettern wie
ach du schande ist also das sind ja auch
so intuitive sachen die überhaupt nicht
willkürlich sind die auch nicht
böswillig gemeint sind ganz oft sondern
die sich einfach in unser denken
eingeprägt haben und dass schon diese
sind einfach tradierte denkmuster auch
die die wir so wie wir hinein gewachsen
sind und die wir auch weiter mit geben
unseren kindern und und jetzt haben wir
die butler noch nicht butler geht jan
schritt gartler würde butler würde
sozusagen noch den schritt weiter gehen
und zu sagen
schon allein die die annahme dass es
zwei geschlechter und nur zwei
geschlechter gibt ist eigentlich schon
ergebnis einer leistung nämlich der
leistung aus ziemlich vielen
unterschiedlichen körpern zwei pole zu
behaupten und alle körper die dann nicht
reinpassen als problematische abweichung
zu markieren sie vielleicht sogar
hormonell oder operativ anzugleichen
alle begehrens formen die sich nicht ein
passen in dieses heterosexuelle
mann/frau schema als irgendwie abnormal
zu markieren und alle geschlechtlichen
identität die sich da nicht einfügen wie
zum beispiel eine transall entität auch
als irgendwie krankhaft oder gestört zu
brandmarken und jetzt gab es natürlich
diese ganze debatte und ich bin jetzt
ganz bös die natürlich angesagt haben
schon das ist gender kaka das ist
journalismus da laufen gegen jahre amok
das ist alles vollkommen absurd und da
gab sie auch ein streit wiederum
innerhalb des feminismus also alice
schwarzer die chatpartner vorgeworfen
hat dass sie eigentlich plötzlich
fokussiert nur noch auf diese frage sind
wir hier alle anerkannt in unserer
unterschiedlichkeit und man eben nicht
mehr spricht dann über ungleiche löhne
über unterdrückung über frauen die von
ihren männern vergewaltigt werden in der
eg und wird nicht als straftatbestand
angeguckt und so weiter ist es nicht
tatsächlich eine schwierigkeit
also ich glaube es sind einfach es ist
ein anderer fokus der debatte auf machen
will und sich zu fragen wie wir
überhaupt
geschlecht also diese zwei geschlechter
erfassen und nichts anderes zulassen
das hindert uns nicht daran trotzdem zu
sagen vergewaltigung innerhalb der eu
ist ein absolut großes problem das kann
auch die julie butler sagen
und das sagt sie auch aber das ändert
nichts daran dass in diesen einzelnen
sozialen positionen in denen sich frauen
befinden das wird die auch mit einem
schritt zurück noch kritisch überdenken
können und uns fragen können gibt es
tatsächlich einfach nur nur diese frauen
und männer dann gibt es nichts anderes
ich glaube das schließt sich nicht aus
und toni bartl wird glaube ich zu
unrecht so oft dafür kritisiert dass sie
körper oder eben dann sexuelle gewalt
und zwar nicht im blick hat aber es kann
nicht alle über alles sprechen
also ich stehe dazu ja ich denke auch
dass die kritik natürlich dann auch
überschießen kommt was sich tatsächlich
sehr oder wo ich die kritik schon
nachvollziehen kann ist dass sie einfach
die eigene historische komponente auch
vergisst
also ich finde jetzt interessant das
buch von 1990 zu lesen und auch zu sehen
wie sich also das unbedingt so sehr
gesteigert das ist genau dieses buch
jetzt zu lesen ja auch fast 30 jahre
später zu lesen und auch zu sehen wie es
historisch einzuordnen ist und wie
gesagt so mit lese ich auch anders es
hat sich auch sehr viel politisch getan
ich denke jetzt auch wir haben jetzt
gerade über die gebärfähigkeit
gesprochen ich würde es nochmal
erweitern
frauchen heißt nicht nur gebären zu
können da geht es auch um probleme die
verhütung abtreibung et cetera also
alles auch themen die auch in der
politik verordnet sind und die den
weiblichen körper auch ganz stark an ein
thema der politik hören lassen sie sagen
in ihrem buch jahren sie fordern
eigentlich eine mutter quote nicht nur
eine frauenquote machen sie damit nicht
genau das was frau miller am anfang
gesagt hat nämlich so ein differenz
feminismus dass sie sagen ja frauen sind
irgendwie ganz anders und eben auch noch
spezifisch mütter seien interessant fand
ich
das tatsächlich also nicht nur bei den
recherchen sondern wenn man auch daten
auswertet ganz spannend wird das auch
von den konservativen diese konflikt
zwischen frauen mit kindern und frauen
ohne kinder angetrieben wird
was ich sehr kontraproduktiv finde auch
in einem feministischen diskurs ja es
gibt ja auch sehr materialistisch im
nächsten einzel die idee und warum der
gedanke der mit acht ländern vorkommt
ist sie tatsächlich wo beginnt
diskriminierung oder wo wie sie das
erste mal wirklich schlagend ja es gibt
diese ungleichbehandlung auch schon
vorher
der streit sich gar nicht ab aber es
gibt einen moment wo tatsächlich eine
ganz besondere existenzielle position
dazu kommt der auf der dann die frau
ganz anders ausgesetzt ist als ein mann
und deshalb die idee einer mutter wurde
nämlich zu sehen auch system kritisch zu
sehen kam eine frau tatsächlich bei
einem meeting um 22 uhr als
alleinerzieherin teilnehmen oder nicht
also wir könnten diese strukturen ändern
deshalb diese idee dieser gedanke einer
mitte quote warum nicht früher ansetzen
warum nicht kinderbetreuungszeiten oder
oder fürsorge arbeit ganz anders
aufteilen
also deshalb auch dieser diese dieser
idee das ist ja auch nicht meine ich
habe diese idee von der frage ob man
auch übernommen die das mal sehr sehr
kontrovers in deutschland diskutiert hat
die soziologin und ich finde dass das
schon sehr schlagen und wäre gerade zb
in österreich und in deutschland
tatsächlich ab 18 uhr für frauen mit
kindern oder ab 17 oft schon wir frauen
mit kindern nichts mehr läuft das heißt
sie kann einfach nicht mehr an wie gut
wenn die männer ein teil der arbeit
übernehmen ist das problem ja also ich
genau ich bin sehr diese mütter quote
auch eher skeptisch weil da geht es ja
vor allem um die bessere vereinbarkeit
von familie und beruf und geschenke also
wir brauchen uns nicht darüber streiten
das ist natürlich mutterschutz angebote
geben muss die eben genau auch vor allem
diese sensiblen phasen wo das kind noch
sehr sehr klein ist und auch tatsächlich
oft noch in dem körperlichen
abhängigkeitsverhältnis von der mutter
steht und so weiter das ist dafür
rahmen geben muss die die bedürfnisse
von mutter und kind schützen geschenkt
aber bei der mutter quote geht es eben
tatsächlich vor allem auch um die
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf und
das ist ja ein anliegen dass männer und
vätern genauso haben sollen und auch
elternteile die jetzt nicht leiblich
verwandt sind mit dem kind das sie
erziehen genauso haben sollen und können
wie mütter
deswegen bin ich da der mann ja auch ein
wie einfach wirklich aber brauchen den
mentalitätswandel darf auch in die
männer väter elternteile die dieses
bedürfnis nach der arbeit nach zeit mit
ihren kindern artikuliert und für sich
in anspruch nehmen und natürlich
brauchen wir da auch einfach auf der
arbeitgeberseite in umdenken ja stimme
ich vollkommen zu es gibt noch einen
zweiten aspekt zur mitte nämlich denen
der repräsentation tatsächlich ja weil
wenden sie jetzt einfach in die politik
schauen natürlich sind die politiker die
auch väter sind aber die gar nicht
sichtbar also die idee werde ich glaube
ich dass ich sie werden nicht dass peter
sich was sie sind als männer sichtbar
dass es ihre rolle und dann sind sie
halt auch noch vater hat mir ganz stark
ja und deshalb auch die idee es ist
nicht nur die vereinbarkeit sondern
tatsächlich auch die repräsentation zu
verändern also auch die interessen jetzt
in der situation von mutterschaft besser
zu repräsentieren also ich gehe
vollkommen recht der bewusstseinswandel
werden hier auch am liebsten brauchen
eltern quote kann man sie vielleicht so
sagen da brauchen wir keine mütter quote
sondern eine eltern quote ja aber die
könnte man mit männern vielleicht sogar
fühlen
das ist mein problem da könnte man
wahrscheinlich mit schild
ich will gut erfüllen ich würde gerne
noch so eine aufnahme auf eine metaebene
auch wechseln und die frage stellt die
haben jetzt über verschiedene figuren
sozusagen gesprochen haben über simon
depot war über schuldig butler
wir haben über nancy fraser auch schon
gesprochen alles philosophieren ist das
ein zufall dass ich den eindruck habt
die impulsgeberin in der feministischen
theorie waren sehr oft philosophinnen
also ich glaube
einerseits ist es kein zufall weil
philosophie sich ja versucht kritisch
mit gesellschaftlichen verhältnissen
auseinanderzusetzen einerseits ist es
würde ich schon sagen auch eher so dass
eine tube pottler natürlich auch
philosophen ist aber ihr impuls kommt
natürlich sehr stark von von sozialen
bewegungen her also ich glaube da ist
immer so ein wechsel seine
wechselwirkung und ganz allgemein glaube
ich auch muss man schon sagen dass die
philosophie gar nicht so gut geeignet
ist sozialen bewegungen zu sagen wo es
eigentlich lang gehen soll wenn man sich
die philosophie selbst anguckt und
schaut wie überdurchschnittlich weiß und
männlich sie eigentlich ist zumindest an
den universitäten und da wird sie
hauptsächlich gelehrt und produziert so
zu sagen sie sind ja beide
gründungsmitglieder bei der sweep also
sie haben sie ein gründungsmitglied des
web journal society for women in
philosophie als eine bewegung eine eine
gemeinschaft von von frauen die sich für
die interessen von frauen belange von
frauen gleichstellung von frauen in der
philosophie ansetzt sie sind
gründungsmitglied zum switch switzerland
das heißt sie machen sich für diese
anliegen ja auch stark dass ich da was
ändert und frauen auch sichtbar werden
in der philosophie ja vielleicht könnte
man auch zu dem was sie gerade gesagt
haben historisch noch anfügen dass
natürlich die die geschlechterfrage die
philosophie schon ewig umtreibt weil der
verdacht dass vielleicht die andere
hälfte der menschheit ähnlich oder sogar
gleich von uns begabt ist diese verdacht
der treibt die philosophie schon ewig um
also schon platt vor zweieinhalbtausend
jahren dafür argumentiert dass der
zugang von frauen zu allen
arbeitsbereichen in der gesellschaft den
kriegsdienst eingeschlossen gleich sein
sollte weil eben die ausprägung von
tugenden und von talenten von
kompetenzen eben nicht geschlechter
abhängig ist das heißt es hat in der
film in der philosophie schon immer auch
männliche feministen gegeben ein anderer
wichtiger name in der etwas späteren
dann in der modernen philosophie wäre da
zum beispiel der liberale sonst werden
will
gleichzeitig und das ist natürlich auch
interessant zu sehen gab es aber hat
diese arm
dass frauen vielleicht gleicher sind als
ihnen zugestanden wird im denken aber
auch in der gesellschaft große
philosophen auch immer wieder dazu
veranlasst nachzuweisen und zu begründen
warum die ungleichbehandlung die
diskriminierung von frauen doch rechtens
sei das hat dazu geführt dass so große
philosophen wie zum beispiel kant und
hegel aufklärungs philosophen
wohlgemerkt die biologie der frau heran
gezogen haben um zu begründen dass die
biologie der frau die vernunft
begabungen mindern würde
und das ist sehr interessant zu sehen
dass gerade in zeiten der aufklärung wo
also die stimme gottes langsam ersetzt
wurde durch die stimme der vernunft die
philosophie gerade die medizin und die
biologie in handschlag gebracht haben um
die angebliche mindere vernunft begabung
der der frau zu das ist diesen frauen
die denken mit den eierstöcken genau
genau und gerade eben weil es in der
philosophie so viel unvernunft geht
und gerade die abwertung von vernunft
fähigkeiten und von von vernunft
kompetenzen so wichtig sind auch für
unterschiedliche ausschlüsse die dann
sozial passieren ist die philosophie
natürlich prädestiniert dazu sich mit
geschlecht auseinanderzusetzen entweder
auf england die partie wie oder auf eine
reaktionäre art und weise das hat ja
auch alles immer zu tun mit stereotypen
und das ist auch sein stichwort das
immer wieder aufgekommen ist das haben
sich am anfang auch schon erwähnt ich
glaube es auch vorgekommen
man spricht die mutter davon was man
sagt es gibt so stereotypen und in der
philosophie ist ein großes thema in
ihrer arbeit auch ein großes thema sie
befassen sich stark mit implizit bayers
nennt man das und stereotypen und auch
der frage der sprachen gerechtigkeit
was ist genau ein stereotyp und was ist
daran problematisch
also einerseits kann man sagen dass
stereotypen einfach kategorien bildung
ist also unser hirn braucht kategorien
in denen mir denken können ich muss sie
als moderatorin erfassen damit ich nicht
plötzlich die ganze zeit einfach
hinschauen wenn ich eine frage erwarte
und
also es sind so kategorien die wir auch
tun damit wir handlungsfähig werden
und jetzt gibt es aber halt stereotype
die problematisch sind weil wenn ich sie
als etwas bestimmtes lese passiert es
auch dass sich dann in sie hinein ganz
viele eigenschaften läge die ich mit
ihnen ist gerade bei moderatorin nicht
als wolle aber eben gerade mit frauen
oder müttern oder anderen sozialen
kategorien
wer da die leute so behandeln
gemäß eines stereotypen den sie also der
gar nicht dem entspricht was die person
eigentlich kann und will und soll aber
so das typische frauen die mögen sowieso
nicht mehr tätig sondern war auch nicht
gut die setzen die entsprechend dann
auch nicht ein für die chefposition in
der analytik abteilung genau das wäre ja
was ist daran jetzt so brisant also ich
versteh ich verstehe sowieso nicht nur
warum warum sprechen im moment gerade so
viel darüber ist ja wirklich so und so
ein hype thema moment naja eben weil
unterschiedliche sozialwissenschaftliche
und psychologische studien ist ja
einfach sehr gut und sehr umfassend
nachgezeichnet haben wie dieser subtile
einfluss von vorurteilen oder von
einfach auch von rollenzuschreibungen
tatsächlich den raum der
selbstbestimmung von insbesondere eben
tendenziell abgewerteten gruppen wie
eben frauen oder auch schwarze menschen
beeinflussen also wenn zum beispiel eine
reine berufsbeschreibung immer nur im
generischen maskulinum beschrieben wird
also zum beispiel da steht dann mann und
es taucht in der berufs reibung immer
nur der arzt auf oder der philosoph oder
der astronaut dann hat es zur folge dass
die frauen die sich mit dieser
berufsbeschreibung beschäftigen sich
diesen beruf weniger zutrauen als wenn
diese berufsbeschreibung nicht im
generischen maskulinum sondern auch mit
weiblichen formen versehen ist dass es
wäre jetzt nur so ein ein beispiel ja um
zu zeigen wie
wie weit eben dieser subtile einfluss
von von rollenzuschreibungen eben wirkt
auch auf unsere eigene hand auf unserer
eigenen handlungen spiel
jetzt hat aber die deutsche philosophin
svenja flaßpöhler die dieses buch
schildert die patente frau über das ja
eine sehr sehr viel gesprochen wird wo
ich auch sagt die frauen müssen mal raus
aus ihrer opferrolle die müssen wir
selber aktiv werden
die hat ja in einer kolumne darauf
hingewiesen dass sie gesagt hat das
generische maskulin ist eigentlich genau
befreiend damit meint sie sie würde es
aus möglichkeit sind zum beispiel nicht
mehr zu sagen ich bin philosophin
sondern ich bin philosoph war ja
eigentlich gut butler doch diese
geschlechter zweiteilung philosophin
philosoph aufheben wollte also könnte
man doch sagen die tür minimal auf von
lehrerinnen und lehrer zu sprechen wir
sind einfach alle lehrer so fertig das
problem ist halt einfach das ist zwar
vielleicht eine nette idee ist aber die
funktioniert halt einfach nicht also
wenn ich jetzt sage ich bin philosoph
dann passiert da überhaupt nichts
irritieren dass von dem was da passiert
ist das was immer passiert wenn wir im
generischen maskulinum sprechen
man stellt sich eben eine gruppe von
männlichen philosophen vor und dann gibt
es da ein paar ausnahme frauen
wenn ich aber wenn ich aber sage
philosophinnen betreten den hörsaal dann
stellt sich ein anderes bild ein und
stellt sich halt einfach das bild ein
es gibt eine gruppe von philosophen und
darunter sind frauen und männer
gleichermaßen und die können das auch
alle sie finden das ja sehr wichtig
diese ganze dieser sprachenstreit
binnen-i sternchen und zu finden sie
wichtig also vielleicht kann man dazu
noch so ein wenig abstrakter sagen ich
verstehe die idee schon also dass man
eine geschlechtsneutrale bezeichnung
suchen möchte und es gibt ja auch
beispiele wie im englischen das welt zu
verwenden wenn man nicht hier oder sie
sagen will sagen kann oder wenn es
einfach nicht notwendig ist also dann
kann ich sagen ja meinte professor days
at bla bla bla und weil es einfach für
den kontext nicht relevant ist welches
geschlecht dieser professor oder diese
professorin eben hat
obwohl es ja eine frau das ist das habe
ich noch nie gehört
das ist in einigen wirklich gang und
gebe inzwischen verstehen liegt dass es
leute gibt die ganz sagen gender kaká
ich sage jetzt noch mal diesen begriff
ich verstehe dass leute das sagen weil
ich verstehe wie die welt momentan
aussieht aber ich glaube es ist ein
bisschen die habe ich soll ich sagen
also ich war die eigene tun zu dem ich
sagen das war also ich glaube dass so
viel aufhebens gemacht wird um dieses
geschlechter sternchen das binnen-i oder
eben menschen das day dort wird zwar
kein aufheben gemacht warum also das
noch interessant das ist so ein bisschen
ausdruck dessen dass die ausgangslage
gegen die unterschiedlichen also auf der
einen seite haben wir leute die sich
nicht vorschreiben lassen möchten wie
sie zu reden haben und dann kommen so
neue dinge wie steinchen die den
lesefluss irgendwie stören und so weiter
das verstehe ich dass das am anfang
irritieren ist aber man muss auch sehen
wie übernehmen ständig neue wörter in
unser vokabular und müssen sie lernen
und das geht sonst ganz gut das heißt da
ist irgendetwas anderes am werk und auf
der anderen seite haben wir menschen wie
frauen
trans menschen eben nicht binäre
identitäten für die das zum teil das
binnen-i oder eben das steinchen nicht
einfach etwas ist das jetzt schön finden
oder noch nett sondern bei diesen
menschen geht es darum endlich auch mal
mit gemeint zu sein wenn man von ihnen
sprechen will
und das passiert mit einem generischen
maskulin und deshalb nicht in der
deutschen sprache weil wir eine
jahrhundertelange geschichte deutsche
sprachen haben weil er das generische
maskulinum eben das männliche geschlecht
bezeichnet und wenn also wenn ich da
frau flaßpöhler irgendwie
zustimmen wollen würde dann müssten wir
eine neue form finden aber nicht eine
bei der wieder zurück zu diesem männlich
zentrieren blick gehen ja also ich für
mich ist keine frage dass gerade wenn es
um offizielle dokumente etc geht es ganz
selbstverständlich sein sollte nicht
form zu finden wo entweder tatsächlich
alle gemeint sind oder wo alle angeführt
sind gut das wird schwierig werden aber
das ist möglich das gibt's jetzt auch
schon in österreich da bin ich schon mal
sehr zuversichtlich was sich
problematischer sehe ist wenn werke der
literatur umgeschrieben werden oder wenn
da ausgetauscht wird da bin ich mehr für
eine kennzeichnung und eine erklärung
also tatsächlich auch den leser mit der
möglichkeit belassen
die informationen die deutung eines
problematischen begriffs wirklich auch
auszulegen damit wieder lesefluss
messwert für mich eine kompromisslösung
ja weil auch das deutsche tatsächlich
eine sehr sehr maskuline sprache ist
aber ja ich denke das wäre möglich und
damit wird die lesbarkeit auch nicht
gestört werden wir sind mitten in der
diskussion aber am ende der zeit und man
könnte noch über viele dinge sprechen
gerade wenn es um sprache geht aber wir
müssen hier bewenden lassen ich danke
ihnen ganz ganz herzlich für die
diskussion
wir haben glaube ich auch gesehen der
feminismus ist nicht nur sehr vielfältig
sondern sind auch ganz viele fragen die
wir weiter diskutieren sollten vielen
dank ja wer der frauenbewegung weiter
auf die spur kommen möchte dem empfehle
ich die neue ab die rote hanna sie
erzählt packend die geschichte der
frauenbewegung in europa nächste woche
feiert jürgen habermas seinen
neunzigsten geburtstag spricht mit china
benhabib und rainer fox die bei ihm
gelernt haben über die ideen des großen
philosophen und jetzt gleich geht's
weiter mit der französischen
filmemacherin war celine laurie doriwwer
die auschwitz überlebt hat mit einem
rückblick auf ein wahrlich bewegtes
leben eine gute woche bis bald
[Musik]